money is essential for keeping a robust
flow of economic activity going
in a world without money I would be
standing outside the gates of Wellesley
College the institution where I have
taught for the past 20 years holding a
sign that says have economics need
chocolate
I would be waiting for lonely at times
for a passerby carrying a board that
says have chocolate need economics
this is what economists call a double
coincidence of wants I want what you
have and you want what I have
but money is a medium of exchange that
cuts through this double coincidence of
wants in effect it allows me to
metaphorically carry around a board that
says have economics need money
meet up with my employer whose board
says have money need economics
and then take my new board which says
have money need chocolate and walk to my
favorite store in town which does in
fact have a board that says have
chocolate need money
finding easier and easier ways for
people to use this medium of Exchange
debit cards credit cards venmo Apple pay
has become a key feature of the modern
economy
money has been an essential part of
economic interactions from the very dawn
of civilization
in the ancient cities of Mesopotamia
people use silver as money to buy Goods
they needed for daily economic activity
the term shackle which meant one-third
of an ounce of silver came into use at
that time as the first known form of
money
gold silver and bronze coins were used
in ancient civilizations in China India
Egypt and Asia Minor
these coins played an important role in
increasing economic activity because
they could be carried around easily were
durable and could be easily divided into
smaller units
properties that we use even today to
characterize what can be used as money
money was also useful for political
influence and control the images of
kings and rulers were placed on coins
taxes could more efficiently and easily
be collected from the populace in the
form of coins which in turn could be
used to attract more soldiers for armies
to conquer new lands or to defend
existing ones
but money was not always synonymous with
precious metals
Furs in cold climates livestock for milk
meat and animal hides salt along Inland
trade routes are all examples of
Commodities that were used as money
because of the intrinsic value they
provided
in fact the word salary which comes from
the Latin word for salt remains an
integral part of our economic vocabulary
today
some forms of money were even more
exotic shells were used as money in both
North America and China
in the South Pacific island of Yap giant
Stone wheels that weigh more than a ton
were used as money
in Eastern Europe behind the Iron
Curtain vodka became a valued commodity
currency since it could be exchanged for
Western Goods when mere paper money in
the form of Russian rubles or East
German marks could not
in prisoner of war camps in World War II
the currency of choice was cigarettes
whereas in prisons today packets of
mackerel fillets are used as money to
trade goods and services
mackerel Rose to prominence after
smoking was prohibited in prison and
prisoners were no longer allowed to buy
cigarettes at the prison commissary
economists think of money as performing
three functions in the economy
money serves as a medium of Exchange
a store of value and a unit of account
the medium of exchange refers to the
willingness of someone to accept the
money in exchange for the good or
service they have to offer
this is what economists consider to be
the most important defining feature of
money
for instance if you went shopping at the
local mall with bags of salt cans of
mackerel or cartons of cigarettes or a
prized milk cow chances are you would
not be leaving them all with the latest
fashions from Zara or a new Xbox game
from GameStop because the owner of the
mall store has little use for a few
dozen extra packs of mackerel
but if you lived at a time or in a place
where those goods could be exchanged for
other goods and services then they would
indeed be accepted as money
a value aspect is also extremely
important for money
a farmer can sell her produce for money
after the Harvest and use the money to
buy things for her family during the
growing season
storing the Harvest is much harder
because of the cost and also because of
natural spoilage
one of the reasons why cigarettes and
foil packs of mackerel are valued in
prison is because they have a longer
shelf life than other Goods that one
could buy at a commissary or one was
given access to In A POW Camp
the store of value aspect is closely
linked to the medium of exchange aspect
we also see the store of value function
Illustrated in currencies of countries
where inflation rates are extremely high
people try to get rid of the paper
currency as soon as they can because the
loss of value makes it undesirable as a
medium of Exchange
feature of money is that the money could
be divided into smaller amounts a metal
coin with half an ounce of silver could
be exchanged for two coins each with a
quarter ounce of silver for example
but this is probably the least important
attribute of money
after all not all Commodities used as
money could easily be divided this way
livestock giant Stone wheels and
unopened foil packs of mackerel are
examples of money that endured despite
not being very good units of account
beginning around the 1800s paper notes
began to be used as money and soon began
to overtake the use of coins
paper money was easier to produce
transport and divide but had the obvious
drawback of not being a commodity there
was no intrinsic value of the note
itself
for people to be comfortable accepting
paper money as a medium of exchange for
the conveniences they needed to be
convinced that the paper money retained
its store or value feature
to this extent the amount of paper
currency that governments could issue
was linked by law to the supply of a
commodity like gold or silver
in the 19th and early 20th centuries
many countries were on a gold standard
which meant that the price of gold in
terms of paper money was fixed by the
government
in the United States under the gold
standard the price of gold was set to 21
dollars per ounce which meant that the
government agreed to buy and sell gold
at that price in exchange for paper
currency
the gold standard collapsed in 1933
the bread and wood system that began in
1945 was based on gold and the US dollar
at a time when the United States
controlled two-thirds of the world's
gold
technically the United States dollar was
fixed to gold at a price of 35 dollars
per ounce but this rate became
increasingly difficult to maintain over
the 1960s as the money supply of U.S
dollars increased creating a mismatch
between the price at which gold could be
directly bought or sold on the World
Market and the rate at which dollars
could be converted to Gold through the
Bretton Woods system
the U.S ended dollar convertibility to
gold in 1971. other countries severed
all links between their money and the
dollar under Breton Woods by 1973.
as a result the currency the coins and
paper money we use today are what we
call Fiat money as opposed to commodity
money the currency has value simply
because people value it as a medium of
Exchange
if you closely examine a dollar bill you
will notice that there is nothing that
says it is convertible to gold or silver
or anything with intrinsic value
instead it says that the note is quote
legal tender for all debts public and
private unquote in other words the US
dollar is valued mostly because of its
value as a medium of exchange both now
and in the future
in the modern economy money is not
merely coins and paper money
instead the bulk of what we consider to
be money comes in the form of deposits
at Banks or other financial institutions
we use various instruments checks debit
cards venmo PayPal to access this money
directly for transactions bypassing the
need to First convert the bank deposits
into paper money by stopping at a bank
or an ATM
in the modern economy money gets
categorized by the Federal Reserve
according to how liquid it is that is
how easy it is to use in transactions
prior to May of 2020 the official
categorizations were M1 which defined
currency and checking account balances
held in banks by individuals and firms
as well as Travelers checks and M2 which
was defined as everything in M1 plus
savings deposits time deposits like
certificates or deposits which cannot be
accessed for a specific period of time
and other deposits where check writing
is limited
intuitively the distinction between the
two is that items in M2 that are not in
M1 are not as liquid that is they cannot
be as easily accessed and used for
conducting transactions as those assets
in M1
Financial innovation has always been
blurring the line between what is M2 and
what is M1 a young person today will not
know what a traveler's check is the
widespread growth in the use of credit
cards and ATM cards during the 1990s has
greatly reduced what used to be a ritual
of international travel as a result
using Travelers checks for doing an
economic transaction in the 2020s would
be much harder than it would have been
in 1990.
similarly in mid-2020 the Federal
Reserve removed the Restriction of a
maximum of six withdrawals a month that
they had imposed on savings account
as a result people could effectively
access the money in certain types of
savings accounts just as easily as they
could access their checking account
balances or the currency in their
wallets this meant that savings account
balances that used to be considered as
M2 were now labeled as M1
this change is vividly seen in the
difference between the M1 and M2 series
for the United States
prior to May 2020 M1 was around 4
trillion dollars and M2 was around 16
trillion dollars
after the recategorization M1 and M2 are
almost identical at around 20 trillion
dollars
given that nominal GDP that same year
was around 22 trillion dollars
effectively about 20 trillion units of
money support 22 trillion dollars worth
of economic activity
currency is only about 10 percent of the
value of M2 around 2.5 trillion dollars
worth of notes and coins that circulate
in the economy
[Music]
thank you